all right Susan is with us in Arizona hi
Susan your question for our dr. D I duck
see okay thank you for taking Michael
engage you in an asset in my life for a
very long time I bless you well thank
you darling you know yeah I am a senior
citizen very physically fit but I have
some underlying conditions like most
people do as you get go to life I was
originally going to babysit my 11 year
old grandson in California during this
process my daughter just appreciate a
job finally thank God a great job and
she's all excited about it
and as the days went by I started
getting every answer she lives with a
gentleman who has a full-time job as
well and I said no I'm just afraid I'm
simply afraid of coming out there I
don't think you'll be wise and I think
you can make other arrangements with
within the family structure because of
our end well yes
right of course okay I like it sure I
understand what you're afraid okay yeah
ever since then she's just this only me
so to speak and I have no contact with
my beloved grandson and I'm no good so
I'm gonna tell you you are good Susan
you're good and what I'm gonna ask you
to do is to give some people some grace
and forgiveness right now because
everybody's scared you know people get
scared they make emotional reaction all
decisions and it sounds like you're
doing what you've been asked to do by
the government and I know that thinking
a matter of toleration all right meadow
if you've got underlying medical
conditions and how old are you okay then
you're supposed to stay home I mean
you're an at-risk person in this
situation yeah and
she doesn't understand that I'm confused
uh well it's at the risk of saying too
much about myself I am the an athlete
and a marathoner and because you're in
good shape you should be able to come on
anyways that was you know I have a
thyroid condition my point is even with
all of that you qualify you're in a
category I know and my wife just turned
60 so we've been joking with her she's
in the category too but I'm not
cuz I don't turn 60 till September so
we're joking around about it right but
the truth the truth is you're in you're
in very good condition but you're in the
category that you're not supposed to be
you know you need to be very very
careful agreed agreed and that's what
your service so why is she mad at you
for that I don't understand because it's
inconvenient for her plans I have to say
yes she has to make other arrangements
and obviously she's just pulling a sort
of you know ragging over [ __ ] I'm sure
this is not the only reason why she's
angry but it's precipitated it this was
a strong mind that yeah guilty and so
unhappy that you know I call my my
grandson I don't say anything I just say
I love you have a good day and yeah I'm
gonna recommend Susan I would write
letters and one of the neatest things is
when we get letters in the house in the
mail and do some things that you can
control because right now your
daughter's made a statement rightly or
wrongly that's not for us to judge or be
a part of but you've got to do what
you've got to do and so you can speak
and be a part of your grandbabies life
by writing letters things he's gonna be
able to hold and read and have for years
and years and years and you can continue
to take care of your physical fitness
and I think it's it's wise to continue
to reach out to your daughter tell her
you love her send her a letter too
and then go find your community there in
Arizona where you are but to continue to
replay this thing over and over in your
mind again is choosing to is in another
sense Callison heart but you're you're
gonna have to decide to not live in
someone else's decisions and then do the
things that you can do each day to to
uplift yourself and to get yourself back
on the saddle here so write letters send
gifts let your daughter know that you
love her and like you mentioned it
sounds like there's more to it than this
one situation and there may be a legacy
here and so start small with letters and
go from there and maybe there's some
things can be done in a few months that
are different than now time does heal a
lot of stuff